What if our world
wasn't the only one
where existence is absurd?
Please refer to the danger menu
for tips on how not to die.
Fight attendant:
If your seat is in the peril row,
you must help us
take the machine apart.
Your reward is more legroom.
One jitter liquid, please.
Would you like to jitter
for one, two, or five hours?
Describe your current
level of activity.
90 percent below average.
Gimme that mild poison!
Woo!
One, two, three!
Server:
I’ll let you two talk
while I go over here
and pretend not to listen.
- Huh, irony.
- Is that irony?
I’m never sure.
This is the adventure
we live for!
Tiny trash.
Being:
The bad moments will pass.
Even the good moments will pass.
That’s what our existence
is all about.
Ow. You licked me
inside the mouth.
This is disgusting,
and it’s perfect!